des surdoses par milliers des services
d'urgence pris d'assaut la crise des
opioïdes ravages toute l'amérique du
nord
c'est le scandale médical le plus
honteux de notre époque seulement qu aux
etats unis l'an dernier 72 mille
personnes sont mortes c'est l'équivalent
de la population d'une ville comme
granby comme drummondville et peu de
gens savent qu'au canada on est le
deuxième pays le plus touché par cette
crise
les occurrences si on les soigne pour
rapidement et en os qui meurt pour la
première fois depuis des décennies
l'espérance de vie pourrait même reculer
mais c'est sans précédent
il ya des gens qui abandonnent tout pour
ça
padoue pharma est accusé d'être l'une
des causes de cette épidémie avec son
ancien produit vedette l'oxycontin perdu
était au courant des abus avec
l'oxycontin et ne rien dire aux états
unis l'entreprise a reconnu certains
secteurs mais au canada
elle affirme avoir tout fait pour
combattre cette crise le problème
c'était le marketing autour de cette
pilule chapelle having et johan bonnaud
ont remonté le fils de l'une des
campagnes de promotions les plus
réussies de l'histoire l'industrie
pharmaceutique et des problèmes qui en
ont suivi au journal as déjà coach pas
de regret
mais oui c'est un drogué avec une drogue
pascal bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean pierre girard revient de loin
ils profitent des petits plaisirs de la
vie ces dernières années des douleurs
grave l'ont amené à prendre des
médicaments qu'ils ont entraînée dans
une spirale dangereuse
ils peinent toujours à s'en remettre ça
fait l'enfant elle enfin l'enjeu
j'étais camionnage et et 15 un camion
cameron a de longues distances qu'on
appelle faire des camions coche au
phoque plus jandola mot merci jamais
même place web du paysage l'ouest
canadien vous c'est durant la crise du
verglas que la durée jean pierre girard
vole en éclats ce jour là ils montent
sur le toit de son camion pour le
déglacer et fait une chute il consulte
un médecin
j'avais perdu la sensation d'une
assiette ces deux côtés d'autres j'avais
une breuleux dans le bas du dos la spar
est comme si un morceau de fer
maintenant elle fait mieux que tu
prenais tout de même atteint naldo bel
ami zahia dont mais c'est là que l'on
commencé d'année des pilules la douleur
ceux qui en souffrent ne sont obsédés
que par une idée la soulager la médecine
les a longtemps négligé mais dans les
années 80 et 90 un mouvement se
développe pour mieux les soigner
c'est alors qu'apparaît un nouveau
remède miracle l'oxycontin j'étais
soulagée d'avoir enfin un médicament que
je pouvais prescrire à mes patients
que ce soit en soins palliatifs au pour
la douleur chronique un produit qui
soulagerait leur douleur avec un minimum
de risques le médicament a été conçu par
une petite compagnie américaine peu doux
pharma direction new york
barry maillot longtemps journaliste au
new york times a été l'un des premiers à
s'intéresser à l'oxycontin se fait 20
ans que je suis cette histoire j'avais
des cheveux quand j'ai commencé en 2003
il publie un premier livre sur le sujet
a été fondé dans les années 50 sa a été
créée par trois frères arthur et
maintenant ça car ils étaient tous les
trois psychiatres
peu doux bâti sa crédibilité avec le ms
compte 1 m/s pour morphine et compte 1
une formule à libération lente qui
permet des doses moins fréquentes
il est prescrit aux patients cancéreux
dr les médecins l'apprécié beaucoup
ça rendait plus facile de traitement des
patients cancéreux
à l'époque c'était une compagnie petit
mais respectée mais le brevet du ms
compte 1 vient bientôt à échéance
le médicament va être copiée par des
génériques
la compétition risque d'être tellement
forte disent eux mêmes ou de plus doux
de 1990 qu'il faut envisager d'autres
types de pioline à libération lente et
la compagnie rêve maintenant de marché
plus large que celui de la douleur
cancéreuse
leur idée c'était il y a plein de gens
qui vivent avec d'autres types de
douleur comme la douleur chronique et on
pourrait utiliser ces médicaments pour
les soulager
le nouvel oxycontin est à base de psycho
donne un ingrédient plus puissant que la
morphine auquel on ajoute la fameuse
formule de libération lente qui permet
un dosage à toutes les douze heures
le médicament est lancée en 1996 aux
états unis à l'époque le marketing de la
part des représentants était
particulièrement intense le docteur
louis winsberg est un spécialiste de la
migraine de chicago world regroupe les
quatre cinq premières années les
représentants pour l'oxycontin était
terrible c'était de la vente sous
pression si on doutait de l'utilisation
sur les personnes âgées
il disait c'est plus sécuritaire
le marketing du médicament aux états
unis est impressionnante
200 millions de dollars de budget en
2001 seulement une force de vente de
centaines de représentants qui reçoivent
de généreux bonus
il existe des techniques de marketing
courante pour les médicaments qui
traitent les brûlures d'estomac la haute
pression le psoriasis ou la dysfonction
sexuelle
mais ce qui est sans précédent
ce que produit à utiliser ces stratégies
pour promouvoir un puissant narcotique
qui peut potentiellement poser la
dépendance aux drogues
c'était un précédent
au canada la promotion de l'oxycontin
prend son ampleur quelques années plus
tard en 2000 lorsque les régimes publics
des provinces décident de le rembourser
j'ai vu le matériel qu'ils diffusaient
c'était le même message que perdus aux
états unis je crois que ça a été conçue
aux états la publicité que nous avons
retrouvé dans ce journal médical
québécois promet une meilleure qualité
de vie parce que l'oxycontin agit sur 12
heures on le recommande pour les
douleurs modérées à intenses qui durent
au moins plusieurs jours sans aucune
limite dans le dosage
mais les recherches de pezou lui ont
démontré qu'elle doit surmonter un
obstacle majeur
vaincre la peur des médecins à l'époque
on avait la crains que tous les patients
qui prenaient des opioïdes devenait
nécessairement tox comment moi je suis
arrivé aux etats-unis pour ma formation
complémentaire début 90 e avait déjà
fait ce changement là dans leurs
pratiques et y était rendu courant de
prescrire des opioïdes
c'était un certain choc de m'acclimater
à cette vision là la docteure boulanger
devient une autorité en traitement de la
douleur au québec
il reste pour certains ces produits là
on ne porte toujours le souhait elle
travaille comme conférencière et
consultante pour plusieurs compagnies
pharmaceutiques dont paul bouffard ma
limite 50 ils veulent avoir des
informations sur les médicaments
ils veulent pour avoir juste
l'impression de représentants
pharmaceutiques qui viens vous parler de
son produit
on veut parler à quelqu'un qui en a déjà
prescrit à des patients qui s'est à
mansle ajustée cette médication l'opp en
ontario aussi rude ou recrute des
experts sept médecins a suivi une
formation dans la région de niagara pour
apprendre à mieux traiter la douleur
connaître leurs produits et ensuite
communiquer à d'autres médecins ce qu'on
avait appris la docteure koivu est
spécialisée en soins palliatifs
à cette époque elle utilise déjà des
opioïdes
mais pour des patients en fin de vie on
vise à rendre les patients confortable
et à court terme la dépendance ne pose
pas de problème quand on parle de
douleurs chroniques
là les gens vont vivre plus longtemps il
faut penser aux effets secondaires et
aux conséquences néfastes que peuvent
avoir les opioïdes net
elle se souvient du message rassurant
transmis durant cette formation
quand c'est pour la douleur la
dépendance n'est pas un problème
nous avons retrouvé une infirmation
semblables dans les publicités de
magazines médicaux en même temps peu du
canada commandite les activités
d'associations du domaine de la douleur
elle finance des études des sondages est
un livre destiné à la formation médicale
qui conclut que la douleur chronique est
sous-traitée on parle de piau phobie
solidarité comme médecin on nous a fait
sentir qu'on laisse à nos pauvres
patients souffrir inutilement ils nous
ont fait sentir coupable et on nous a
rassurés les patients ne vont pas
devenir dépendant de la cram dépt
et un autre message vient apaiser les
craintes des médecins les opioïdes à
libération lente comme l'oxycontin
présenterait moins de risques d'abus
dès 2001 les ventes d'oxycontin dépasse
largement le milliard de dollars aux
états unis est déjà dans les régions
pauvres de l'est du pays
les mort par surdose se comptent par
centaines pour l'entreprise ce sont les
toxicomanes le problème
la suite de notre enquête dans un
instant
[Applaudissements]
2003 terre neuve et la nouvelle écosse
sont les premières provinces a signalé
un nombre croissant de surdoses et de
crimes liés à la consommation de piau id
le produit particulièrement convoités
par les toxicomanes
l'oxycontin le directeur général de
perdus au canada john stewart est
interpellé on travaille de plusieurs
façons avec le gouvernement de
terre-neuve pour réduire les abus relié
à l'oxycontin le gouvernement de
terre-neuve met sur pied un groupe de
travail
parmi ces conclusions les autorités sont
dépassées par le problème
le rapport souligne que les
prescriptions de pionnier de augmente et
à des doses inquiétante le détournement
de l'oxycontin vers le marché noir est
répandue comme à chaque fois qu'elle est
visée la compagnie affirme que ce n'est
pas le médicament qui est en cause mais
plutôt ceux qui en abusent
les activités criminelles ne devrait pas
dicter les politiques de santé
pour contrer ces abus il faut de
l'éducation et de meilleurs traitements
il faut des lois plus sévères contre le
détournement de médicaments et ne pas
pénaliser les patients et les médecins
qui les traitent
dans les années 2000 les ventes
d'oxycontin ont sans cesse d'augmenter
et les problèmes reliés à sa
consommation aussi certaines pharmacies
ne veulent même plus en conserver les
toxicomanes ont vite découvert comment
libérer rapidement une forte dose de
drogue
c'est super facile sous les craintes
dans une cuillère se met de l'eau
chauffe trouve une veine et tu te
l'injectent à london en ontario
nous avons rencontré josh il raconte
comment en 2006 il a succombé à
l'oxycontin c'est la meilleure sensation
au monde
mille fois ya des gens qui abandonnent
tout pour ça c'est tellement bien quand
tu es là dessus au début vous l'obtenez
d'un médecin le médecins qui
prescrivaient après je les ai achetés
dans la rue des gens qui vendaient leurs
médicaments de prescription
le docteur valdan qu'elle lui doit
traiter de plus en plus de cas de
dépendance non seulement chez les
toxicomanes
mais chez les patients en douleur
chronique whistle
on voyait arriver tous ces patients qui
avaient des problèmes avec l'oxycontin
c'était choquant il prenait de fortes
doses pour des douleurs plutôt mineures
il était devenu dépendant il fallait les
mettre sur la méthadone
c'était honteux de voir comment les
médecins se sont laissés influencer et
oui on va changer notre façon prescrire
sur quelle base quelles recherches dire
que c'est efficace sûr et que ça ne crée
pas de dépendance et ça sans aucun
fondement nous avons voulu voir les
études soumises pour l'approbation de
l'oxycontin santé canada nous en a
refusé l'accès mais elle nous répond que
c'était probablement les mêmes qu'aux
états unis nous avons pu consulter le
dossier soumis à la food and drug
administration
au milieu des années 90 le fonctionnaire
responsable conclut que l'oxycontin n'a
pas démontré davantage significatif à
part son dosage moins fréquents il
faudra faire attention à ce que la
compagnie ne prétendent pas dans sa
promotion qu'il est supérieur
aucune étude sur l'efficacité à long
terme du médicament pour la douleur
chronique
pas plus que sur les risques de
dépendances moins de 1%
ce chiffre a été citée en référence
pendant des années au canada et aux
états unis pour parler des risques de
dépendance des opioïdes tous à dire que
c'était moins de 20 % c'était vraiment
malhonnête ridiculement bas ce n'était
pas une étude faite par la compagnie
c'était dans un autre bus avec des
patients hospitalisés en 1999
le docteur robens de chicago est
approché par perdre ou pour devenir un
de ces conférenciers il nous révèle
qu'elle a aussi financé une étude sur
l'oxycontin ils m'ont donné une petite
subvention pour une étude rétrospective
j'ai examiné l'évolution de mes patients
traités avec l'oxycontin
13 % d'entre eux avaient développé de la
dépendance lorsqu il communique ses
résultats après d'où elle rompt tout
contact avec lui le dr rabin va tout de
même publié sa recherche dans une petite
revue spécialisée
gimont bêtement laissé tomber contacté à
propos de cette étude la compagnie aux
etats-unis nous a dit qu'elle jugeait
ces résultats inexacts
parce qu'on ne précisait pas
suffisamment les critères on définir la
dépendance donc se sait ce sont des
extraits votre dossier médical et on
impulse il tout votre voiture votre
historique les différents médicaments
que vous preniez après son accident
les douleurs au dos de jean pierre
girard s'aggrave il subi plusieurs
opérations
son médecin lui fait essayer différents
opioïdes dont le xi compte un camp qui
changerait de soki n'zinga revient c'est
un autre tweet oms a fait la même a fait
passer est un dérivé de mon fils les
mavs expliquer le pourquoi qu'il faisait
ça parce qu'en corse a deux souhaits
trouvent ils voulaient pour monter une
rouste aux rythmes et aux sermons seul
des douze poules ou lui faisait
confiance
encore aujourd'hui je fais confiance
entièrement chaque fois ils tolèrent des
doses de plus en plus forte
dois-je vous faites pas ce que je peux
m'endormir je m'ennuie je parlais on
avait des amis qui venaient jetons
m'endormir genre comme sur le paf
de boer endroit en train d'accorder le
cadeau que je demain matin l'offre dont
vous voyez le double où l on voit que
vous êtes à m'endormir de goulée comme
ça comme ça que votre femme elle avait
tout filmé ça parce que passer parce que
là c'est ce serait une carrière que je
tombais a dormi comme ça son médecin est
inquiète et ne veut plus augmenté ses
doses et une ambiance froid l'été parce
que le cas ou alors chez ge que tous
fassent un peu de retard j'ai demandé
pourquoi il dit la dose petit frein on
donnerait son cheval de travail itt
ombre il sait même pas comment tu fais
pour prendre sopn capable de domaine et
que la décision a été prise que vous
envoyez à désintox au départ je t'ai pas
bon sens parce que les musées aux
anneaux les désaccords se plaint de
réglages
je suis pourtant pas de drogue
mais oui c'est une dose de spray
surprend pas dans l'oubli stand royce
une halte et à draguer avec drogues
prescrites
hormis 2007 en virginie trois dirigeants
de perdre ou plaide coupable d'avoir
fait de la publicité mensongère en
affirmant que l'oxycontin était moins
sujet à la dépendance et aux abus que
les autres médicaments contre la douleur
peu doué ses dirigeants vont payer une
amende de 635 millions de dollars il
évite un procès qui aurait exposé la
preuve accumulée par les procureurs
barry mahieu a récemment eu accès à
cette preuve
j'aurais été un tournant
le rapport confidentiel du département
de la justice révèle que la compagnie a
su très tôt que son ms contin reconnu
pour la douleur cancéreuse était
détournée et valait cher sur le marché
noir
en 1998 un des mémos internes signale ce
problème à vancouver
le directeur général de peugeot au
canada john stewart envoie à ses
collègues américains une étude publiée
dans un important magazine médical
canadien
le numéro inclut aussi l'éditorial d'un
médecin qui s'inquiètent de l'arrivée de
l'oxycontin il était très clair cette
idée que les opioïdes à libération lente
sont plus sécuritaires
c'est moins sujets aux abus c'était une
farce et déjà dès cette période
l'oxycontin était écrasé consommée par
les toxicomanes aux états unis et la
compagnie le savez produits étaient au
courant des abus avec le petit copain et
nordine ghrib
selon barry mahieu la divulgation de ces
informations auraient peut-être ralenti
la crise les médecins auraient vu à quel
point la compagnie et les avait trompés
à quel point elle leur avait menti et
trahi leur confiance
révélation étonnante santé canada nous
écrit que ce n'est qu'en 2010 que pearl
ou pharma l'a formellement approché pour
discuter des problèmes d'abus de
l'oxycontin après la pause vous allez
voir que c'est pas facile de freiner
lusage et la prescription des opioïdes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais 2018 la société canadienne de la
douleur tient son congrès annuel à
montréal tout le milieu est secoué par
la crise des opioïdes nous tombons en
plein débat il y a ceux qui dénoncent la
surprescription d'opioïdes et ce qu'ils
disent s'ils ont prescrit - on laisse
tomber les patients souffrant de
douleurs chroniques
surtout que pour plusieurs la
prescription de pioline n'est pas
responsable de la crise actuelle
oui au soleil nouvelle et 10 pour cent
dans nbc
le pionnier qui retient maintenant toute
l'attention c'est le fentanyl il fait
des ravages surtout en colombie
britannique
il est 50 fois plus puissant que la
morphine
on parle ici surtout du fentanyl
illégales venues de la chine pas de
celui obtenu sans ordonnance
les surdoses et les morts défraie les
manchettes et font oublier l'origine du
problème selon ce chercheur verio europe
et un feeling mad la demande pour les
opioïdes illégaux et a été créé il ya
cinq dix quinze ans par la
surprescription elle vient
principalement de notre système de santé
de nombreuses compagnies pharmaceutiques
ont aussi profité de cette demande et
contribué à répandre l'usagé des
opioïdes
mais le médicament qui a tout déclenché
selon lui c'est l'oxycontin qu il a
ouvert la porte il a été au coeur de
cette vague
la crise a démarré avec l'oxycontin
effet terriblement augmenté le nombre de
patients dépendants
les fabricants ont banalisé les opioïdes
dans la société
maintenant qu'ils sont difficiles à
obtenir le fentanyl est la moins chère
et certains vont en acheter
la vague est devenu impossible à freiner
près de 4000 mort par surdose en 2017
la majorité sont maintenant liés au
fatah nil mais de nombreux décès sont
encore dues à des opioïdes prescrits au
québec notamment
d'abord les opioïdes ne devrait pas être
le premier choix pour le traitement de
la douleur chronique non cancéreuse au
congrès de la société canadienne de la
douleur jean basset présente les toutes
dernières lignes directrices canadiennes
concernant la prescription de pioline
elles sont beaucoup plus restrictif on
recommande un dosage maximum beaucoup
plus bas pour les patients qui débute
mais la recommandation la plus
controversée
on suggère aux médecins dont les
patients prennent déjà de fortes
quantités de piau id de les inciter à
diminuer leur dose quitte à
potentiellement arrêter le traitement ou
un peu plus les taux sont élevés plus il
ya de risques
ce président d'une association de
patients n'est pas d'accord certains
patients prennent ces médicaments pour
la douleur depuis plus de 20 ans ils
vont bien peut-être qu'ils travaillent
ou sont très actifs et il faudrait leur
enlever ça le maximum recommandée est de
90 mg par jour
pour vous donner une idée jean pierre
girard a déjà pris l'équivalent de 19
fois cette dose
mais pour revenir à des doses moins
risqué le défi est colossal pour les
médecins traitants comme pour les
patients
jean pierre girard va mieux mais il a
traversé toute une épreuve
la désintoxication on est il n'avait pas
un claquement des médicaments fait quand
on se rencontrait le petit gros j'ai
rien dit on a fait 17 morts
[Musique]
combien de temps vous avez vous n'avez
pas pu conduire de j'ai peut-être de
proches de 3 1 qui a fallu à chaque fois
que je descends dans marianne on me
rendez vous ça me prenait un compte
twitter avec moi
après son sevrage à la méthadone on lui
a prescrit un traitement semblable qu'il
prend depuis cinq ans je pense mais
portant de procès c'est pas de la drogue
ce sont des médicaments de substitution
la docteure marie ève morin reçoit de
plus en plus de patients comme
jean-pierre dans sa clinique de montréal
ces dernières années trois personnes sur
quatre viennent la voir pour une
dépendance à des opioïdes prescrit êtes
obligés de refuser des wii ou encore on
essaie de prendre une entente avec le
médecin qui nous réfère le patient pour
the new envol induiront va débuter le
traitement est ensuite envolé ces
contenus est suivie il faut ça
fonctionne dès fois ça fonctionne pas
mais ce qui est sûr en fait c'est que
les opioïdes si on les soigne pour
rapidement il y en a qui meurt c'est
qu'on les repère spatial moment de
recueillement prime de la preuve qu'on
l'ait fait en une seule barre daniel
sait ce que c'est que d'être privé
soudainement de no piot id serveuse dans
un restaurant
elle avait développé un grave problème à
l'épaule mais ses finances ne lui
permettent pas de cesser de travailler
j'ai toujours essayé juillet pro avec
basso à notre engagement fasse opérer
cette rigueur aussi l'arrivée ensuite ça
prévaut ce mot que je suis arrivé j'ai
pour mon père et après l'opération
le jury du diesel est ce que le vigile
opérations les plus dangereux que j'ai
prise il paraît à peu près pour
mauvaises créances avoir moins manger
j'ai voulu arrêter le vj compris que je
te vois capable de tout une fois sa
prescription échu daniel se tourner vers
le marché noir mois s'était passé
ce que je connaisse le jeu quelqu'un qui
a demandé sauf que je savais pas ce que
je peux te souviens vaguement les deux
fois j'ai dormi longtemps donc il faut
que je suis en plus parce que ça marche
à pau mais la fox
je suppose que je prenne elle finit par
avoir une place en clinique
elle est maintenant traité pour sa
dépendance pour venir en aide aux
patients et aux toxicomanes il ne
suffira pas de diminuer les
prescriptions de piau id
il faudra aussi des services
supplémentaires pour les accompagner
même au québec où le problème est moins
criant on a un taux de décès qui est
dans les plus faibles un taux de
citation qui a le plus fait on a des
taux de prescription aussi qu'ils sont
les dents les plus faibles au canada
donc on est un petit peu épargné de ça
mais malgré tout on voit quand même une
hausse des décès et donc on s'en est
quand même préoccupé par la situation
l'experte en traitement de la douleur la
docteure aline boulanger a collaboré
avec plusieurs compagnies dont plus doux
ferment dans le passé et la plaie à un
usage plus répandu des opioïdes pour
traiter la douleur chronique ce que
plusieurs médecins remettent en question
maintenant est ce que vous partagez ce
même genre de réflexion là a fortiori
écouter un passant qui développerait un
troc 12 ans est impatient trop ok donc
fier claque sujet des passants qui
présente des troupes charge
malheureusement oui jo a déçus elle
dirige la clinique antidouleur du centre
hospitalier universitaire de montréal
sur le site internet de votre clinique
de la douleur du chemin on disait
récemment la dépendance est rare quand
le piia s'essaie à soulager la douleur
est ce que c'est juste mais on cherche
un malheureux si cet accord là dessus
sont à 17 ans elle était récemment on a
longtemps cru que
quand on avait de la douleur qu'il n'y
avait pratiquement pas de chances de
développer un abus ou non une toxicomane
cette affirmation a longtemps été l'un
des arguments de vente de l'oxycontin
parce que la compagnie faisait ça joue
très peu au compte des monnaies les
compagnies pharmaceutiques et je pense
que c'est un plus qu'un nom qui le
disait je crois qu'on avait cette
impression lors que la douleur pouvait
prévenir l'apparition de la toxicomanie
c'est une impression qui a évolué le
fait d'avoir une douleur mais pour la
personne à l'abri d'une éventuelle
toxicomanes le comité de jesse une base
s'est établie à 5 et demi pour cent le
risque de développer une dépendance aux
opioïdes dans les cas de douleurs
chroniques
pas moins de 1% le chiffre cité pendant
des années une personne sur 20 ça me
paraît un nombre important la société
canadienne de la douleur associée dans
le passé a perdu pharma souhaite
maintenant prendre ses distances il faut
éviter que l'histoire se répète
on a appris des liens trop étroits de
certaines associations médicales avec
les compagnies pharmaceutiques
surtout en ce qui concerne des opioïdes
il nous faut garder une distance
en attendant on constate que peloux
pharma est toujours l'un des principaux
commanditaires du congrès pour mettre
fin à cette dépendance
la présidente souhaiterait plus de
financement des gouvernements pour qu'on
puisse se priver de l'aide des fermes un
succès car ça a été un vrai gâchis
dans un instant la fin de l'oxycontin
mais les problèmes continuent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
london en ontario cette ville au passé
industriel florissant affiches partout
son déclin aux problèmes socio
économiques s'ajoutent ceux de la
consommation de drogues nous dit le
responsable du bureau de santé de la
ville ici ce sont les au pied de
prescription qui sont les plus courantes
c'est notre principale source de
problèmes on entre trois et six mille
utilisateurs de drogues par injection
en 2011 la ville vite un pic de
mortalité
les ventes de l'oxycontin sont alors à
leur sommet c'est ce médicament qui fait
le plus de victimes
un an plus tard pedoux pharma lance une
nouvelle version de l'oxycontin look
sineo un comprimé moins facile à écraser
d'accéder au look sineo est un bon
produit mais le moment choisi pour le
lancer n'est pas dû au hasard
le brevet de l'oxycontin arrivait à
échéance et les génériques allait être
commercialisé la compagnie se livrent un
lobbying intense à ottawa pour empêcher
ces compétiteurs de lancer des
génériques de son vieil oxycontin dans
l'intérêt public dit elle
finalement ottawa ne cède pas et
autorise les génériques
de plus le nouvel os xi néo ne sera pas
remboursé sauf exception par la majorité
des provinces
il sera moins est prescrit est moins
présent dans la rue et vossen coup les
gens l'ont remplacé par un autre
pionnier le plus répandu et en
l'hydromorphone il hydromorphes compte 1
est un autre pionnier de la libération
lente de plus doux pharma
pour lequel il ya tout un marché pour un
12 mg diderot more content c'est 25 $
citoyens aux abords la ville de london a
dû ouvrir l'an dernier un centre
temporaire d'injection supervisée traver
un habitué nous a décrit sa dure réalité
n'est pas d'emploi
ce que je fais à longueur de journée si
trouver de l'argent pour acheter ma dose
quand on fait ça dans une ruelle ou
ailleurs on n'est jamais tranquille ici
c'est confortable tel personnel médical
ont évité les surdoses ou même la mort
ça arrive souvent l'hydromorphone temps
est maintenant le pionnier d'un piqué
dans le plus grand nombre de décès à
london et une équipe de médecins a
découvert qu'il fait aussi courir
d'autres risques aux toxicomanes le
médicament ne se dissout pas bien dans
l'eau il est fait pour se dissoudre
lentement dans l'estomac
après la première injection il reste
environ 45% de la substance
ça vaut beaucoup d'argent les
toxicomanes vont le réutiliser mais il
est souvent contaminée par des bactéries
le mécanisme de libération lente aide à
conserver les bactéries particulièrement
celles qui infecte le coeur et cause
l'endocardite london est aux prises avec
une augmentation marquée de cette grave
maladie infectieuse qui sollicitent les
services de santé
ces patients deviennent très malades ont
besoin de chirurgie importante et
passent plusieurs semaines à l'hôpital
de quatre à six semaines
c'est difficile pour eux mais aussi pour
les hôpitaux qui manquent de lits selon
les chiffres que nous avons obtenu les
pharmacies canadiennes ont vendu pour
645 millions de dollars d'ide romoff
compte 1 depuis cinq ans c'est le
pionnier de le plus lucratif au pays
le docteur sylvain nous a confié qu'il a
demandé les échantillons du médicament
apple doux pour ses recherches sur ce
problème
la compagnie a refusé peu doux n'a pas
voulu nous expliquer pourquoi
après la pause on s'interroge sur qui
doit porter le blâme
[Musique]
en mars dernier des manifestants
envahissent le metropolitan museum of
art de new york
c'est aile du musée a été financée par
la famille c'est clair qui a fondé peu
d'effarement
les sept l'air sont de grands
philanthropes leur fondation soutiennent
les grands musées du monde des hôpitaux
et de la recherche universitaire même
ici à l'université mcgill
on réclame qu'il finance plutôt des
centres de désintoxication aux états
unis la compagnie perdre ou fait l'objet
de plusieurs centaines de poursuite des
plaintes qui signe aussi les autres
fabricants et distributeurs de piau ide
au canada la compagnie a plutôt été à
l'abri de la tourmente
à l'exception d'un recours collectif
lancé dans quatre provinces que plus
doux a accepté l'an dernier de régler
pour 20 millions de dollars tout en
admettant aucune faute mais 20 millions
seulement 2 millions sans vos province à
écouter à chaque année j'ai fait le coup
dans les urgences d empoisonnement dû
aux opioïdes
on parle de dizaines de millions par
année dans l'idée dans les provinces
dans les auges en obtint mais un juge la
saskatchewan a refusé d'entériner
l'entente il a estimé le dédommagements
insuffisants pour les victimes comme
pour les provinces
sur les compagnies pharmaceutiques
doivent prendre leurs responsabilités et
faire passer la vie des gens avant le
profit et les pressions s'accentuent au
pays la colombie britannique vient de
lancer une poursuite contre une
quarantaine de fabricants et
distributeurs de piau ide dont +12
pharma pour récupérer les coûts associés
à la crise un groupe de chercheurs
pressent ottawa de lancer une enquête
criminelle contre +12 6 obtenait gain de
cause ce serait une première selon cet
expert
jusqu'à présent les santé canada a
jamais poursuivi il joue et un exécutif
d'une compagnie pharmaceutique se
retrouver en prison au canada ou quoi
que ce soit pour des pratiques
problématiques santé canada nous a dit
qu'elle n'écarte pas la possibilité de
porter des accusations criminelles pour
des comportements inappropriés du passé
elle ajoute que des lois plus fortes
sont maintenant en place pour lui
permettre de le faire
suite à nos nombreuses questions rue du
canada nous a transmis un bref courriel
elle se dit très préoccupé par la crise
elle souligne s'être toujours fait un
point d'honneur de respecter les règles
et les lois canadiennes elle annoncé
qu'elle développe un traitement
d'urgence pour les surdoses de piau id
il constitue une autre mesure concrète
dans nos efforts visant à répondre à ce
grave problème de santé publique qui se
posent aux canadiens ce grave problème
que peut nous a elle même contribué à
créer la compagnie occupe toujours le
tiers du marché des opioïdes au canada
le docteur khan crois que santé canada a
aussi sa part de blâme
en 2009 il lui a écrit pour se plaindre
d'inexactitudes dans la documentation
accompagnant l'oxycontin santé canada
m'a répondu si vous avez des inquiétudes
contacté le fabricant s'est tassée
chacun ce médicament causait du tort aux
gens provoqué des décès et santé canada
dit ce n'est pas notre problème
pour lui toute cette histoire se résume
en quelques mots tva
c'est le plus grand scandale médical de
notre époque et ce cri de soi reid
c'est une histoire de cupidité de
malhonnêteté et de la part des médecins
de manque de courage tâche
et le résultat c'est des milliers de
morts il faut reconnaître nos torts
qu'on est désolé et ensuite il faut
âgées et surtout il ne faut pas
stigmatiser ceux qui souffrent de ce
problème de santé que nous avons créés
jean pierre girard tente de reprendre
une vie normale mais il a dû renoncer à
son métier de camionneur s'est fait des
shows ici tu bouges pas dans ma cour
pendant huit ans voilà des fois nous as
may foot après une faute a pris un
navire votre mac un iphone à sa droite
tu peux pas revenir en arrière luis a
white les a fait que j'ai eu à cause des
médicaments qu'il est pris ben oui j'en
ai fait d'autres choses il apprend à
vivre avec la douleur une douleur pour
laquelle il n'y a toujours pas de remède
miracle
[Musique]
on espère que vous avez apprécié
l'enquète de ce soir d'ailleurs vous
pourrez trouver des informations
complémentaires sur notre page web
au nom de toute l'équipe merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là et on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]